un proyecto de ley firmado en mayo por
el gobernador de texas que prohíbe el
aborto pasadas las 6 semanas de
gestación acaba de entrar en vigor greg
abbott defendió la norma y dijo que
salvará a bilbao ver el proyecto de ley
que estoy a punto de firmar asegura la
vida de cada niño por nacer que tiene un
latido y que estará a salvo de los
estragos del aborto por nueve a favor de
la norma llamada latido es una de las
más restrictivas en el país sin hacer
excepciones para casos de violación o
incesto y solo por una emergencia médica
a las seis semanas muchas mujeres ni
siquiera están conscientes de que están
embarazadas grupos pro aborto dicen que
hasta el 90% de los procedimientos
practicados en texas se dan después de
las 6 semanas lo que convierte la ley en
una prohibición de facto del aborto en
el estado y la ley de texas va más allá
alentando a los ciudadanos a demandar a
aquellos que ayuden a una mujer a
abortar al recompensarlos con 10 mil
dólares americanos si es que tienen
éxito la unión americana por las
libertades civiles dice que la ley crea
un plan de cazarrecompensas para
incentivar demandas por acoso
individuos privados incluyendo
activistas antiaborto sin conexión con
sus pacientes ahora pueden demandar a
quien sea que crean que esté
proporcionando abortos o ayudando a
alguien a tener acceso al aborto después
de seis semanas
esto incluye trabajadores de la salud
clero conductores de vehículo compartido
plantaron hood la unión americana de
libertades civiles y otros grupos de
derechos lanzaron un llamamiento de
emergencia ante la corte suprema para
detener la ley pero la corte no
respondió antes no se había permitido
que ninguna otra prohibición de seis
semanas entrar en vigor ni siquiera
brevemente los expertos legales vieron
que la ley es inconstitucional
prohibiciones similares han sido
anuladas por la corte como la violación
de robbie wait la sentencia histórica
que legalizó el aborto pero con una
nueva composición conservadora en la
corte suprema- el derecho al aborto está
cada vez más bajo presión